>>> IT HAS BEEN A ROUGH START TO
THE SUMMER TRAVEL SEASON AS
AIRLINES YESTERDAY CANCELED MORE
THAN 1,000 FLIGHTS AND ANOTHER
3,400 WERE DELAYED.
THE DISRUPTIONS ARE LARGELY
BECAUSE OF WEATHER ON THE EAST
COAST AND CNN'S PETE MUNTEAN IS
LIVE AT REAGAN NATIONAL AIRPORT
WHERE A LOT OF PEOPLE I'M SURE,
PETE, THIS MORNING ARE HOPING
THEY DO NOT EXPERIENCE THE DAY
THAT TRAVELERS HAD YESTERDAY.
>> Reporter: THAT'S RIGHT,
KAITLAN.
AIRLINES STILL REELING FROM THAT
BAD WEATHER YESTERDAY.
JUST CHECK FLIGHT AWARE, MORE
THAN 1,400 CANCELLATIONES IN
TOTAL NATIONWIDE JUST YESTERDAY.
THE CANCELLATIONS ARE ALREADY
PILING UP TODAY, MORE THAN 500
TODAY SO FAR.
REMEMBER THAT AIRLINES GOT A LOT
SMALLER OVER THE PANDEMIC, THAT
MAKES BAD WEATHER HIT THEM EVEN
HARDER.
THAT MEANS THIS IS GOING TO BE A
BIG SUMMER OF FLIGHT
CANCELLATIONS.
IT IS AN EXPENSIVE SUMMER OF
TRAVEL STRESS AT AIRPORTS
WORLDWIDE WITH AIRLINES
STRUGGLING WITH STAFFING
SHORTAGES AND SCHEDULE MELT
DOWNS.
>> WE'RE STRANDED.
>> Reporter: GINA MORALE LESS'
$1,000 FLIGHT TO A PAGEANT WAS
CANCELED ONLY TO REBOOK ON A
DIFFERENT FLIGHT THAT WAS ALSO
CANCELED.
FROM THURSDAY TO MONDAY AIRLINES
IN THE U.S. CANCELED MORE THAN
5,400 FLIGHTS.
>> IT MAKES ME NOT WANT TO
TRAVEL AT ALL.
GO ON NO AIRPLANES, NOTHING.
>> Reporter: NEW ANALYSIS FROM
TRAVEL SITE HOPPER SAYS FLIGHT
CANCELLATIONS HAVE JUMPED 34% IN
THE LAST MONTH, DOMESTIC TICKET
PRICES ARE UP, TOO, BY 18% SINCE
2019, EVEN STILL PASSENGERS ARE
PACKING PLANES, LAST WEEKEND THE
TSA SCREENED MORE PEOPLE AT
AIRPORTS NATIONWIDE THAN ANY
WEEKEND SINCE THE START OF THE
PANDEMIC.
>> TRAVELERS ARE WILLING TO PAY
MORE AND THEY'RE WILLING TO FACE
POTENTIAL DISRUPTIONS BECAUSE
THEY REALLY WANT TO GO ON THESE
TRIPS THAT THEY'VE PUT OFF IN
MANY CASES FOR TWO YEARS.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALL
BEING HERE TODAY.
>> Reporter: AIRLINE CEOs
LOBBIED CONGRESS FOR $50 BILLION
IN PANDEMIC AID TO KEEP WORKERS
ON THE JOB, EVEN STILL AIRLINES
GOT SMALLER, OFFERING EMPLOYEES
EARLY OUT AND RETIREMENT
PACKAGES.
>> I'M TREMENDOUSLY ANGRY.
>> Reporter: AIRLINE CONSUMER
ADVOCATE BILL McGEE SAYS
AIRLINES ARE NOT KEEPING UP
THEIR END OF THE DEAL.
SOUTHWEST AND DELTA PILOTS HAVE
PICKETED TO SAY THEY ARE
OVERWORKED.
AIRLINES INSIST THEY ARE HIRING
HUNDREDS OF NEW WORKERS EACH
MONTH WHILE DEALING WITH STORMS
AND AIR TRAFFIC CONTROL ISSUES.
>> I'VE NEVER SEEN A MELT DOWN
OF THIS PROPORTION.
THE FACT IS THE AIRLINES STILL
REFUSE TO OWN THIS.
>> Reporter: TRANSPORTATION
SECRETARY PETE BUTTIGIEG HAS
TOLD AIRLINE CEOs TO STRESS TEST
THEIR SCHEDULES AND ADD CUSTOMER
SERVICE STAFF WITH JULY 4th
TRAVEL ON THE HORIZON.
AAA FORECASTS 47.9 MILLION
AMERICANS WILL TRAVEL FOR THE
HOLIDAY BUT A SHRINKING SHARE
WILL TAKE TO THE SKIES.
>> YOU CAN'T IGNORE WE HAVE HAD
SIX MONTHS OF CONSTANT STORIES
OF DELAYS, CANCELLATIONS, BAD
WEATHER, LONG LINES, FRUSTRATION
AND SOMEBODY MAY DECIDE I THINK
IT'S EASIER FOR ME JUST TO HOP
IN THE CAR AND GO THIS YEAR.
>> Reporter: WE ALSO HEARD FROM
UNITED AIRLINES CEO SCOTT KIRBY
ABOUT THIS AND HE PUT SOME OF
THE BLAME OF CANCELLATIONS BACK
ON THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
HE SAYS THAT THE FAA NEEDS TO
MORE PROPERLY STAFF UP ON AIR
TRAFFIC CONTROLLERS TO ALLEVIATE
SOME DELAYS.
THE FAA TELLS ME THEY INSIST IT
IS NOT AN ISSUE AND IS MOVING
CONTROLLERS AROUND TO HOT SPOTS
LIKE FLORIDA.
I ALSO SPOKE TO HOUSE
TRANSPORTATION CHAIR PETER
DeFAZIO ABOUT THIS.
HE WANTS A READOUT FROM EVERY
MAJOR AIRLINE ABOUT HOW MANY
PILOTS THEY HAVE ON STAFF RIGHT
NOW.
WE WILL SEE, KAITLAN, IF THIS
MEANS EVEN MORE CONGRESSIONAL
HEARINGS FOR THE AIRLINES.
>> YEAH, YOU CAN TOTAL